you have these three giant companies
BlackRock State Street in Vanguard who
own who all own each other you know
BlackRock has 10 trillion dollars under
man these are all private Equity
companies yeah the biggest companies in
the world and they and they are they own
I think they own uh 88 of the s p 500s
those three companies say on 88 of the S
P 500 so they already own everything and
now they've decided
they're gonna buy every single family
home in America so
um they're on track Now to control to
own the corporate control of the 60 of
the of the single family homes in
America within six years so so you're
saying so when somebody comes in with a
cash offer it's it's usually from yeah
it's an LLC with some ambiguous name a
shell Corp right and if you if you
follow the you know the breadcrumbs
it'll go back to Black Box Vanguard
State Street and they want to own all of
them and you know and I mean ironically
and I you know I don't want to feed into
anybody's personal Air Bud
you know it's playing with matches and a
dynamite you know yeah with you in
the room but uh yeah but Larry Fink
who's uh who is the CEO of BlackRock is
also on the board of the world economic
Forum yes which you know their Mantra is
we're going to have this great reset
what does that mean it means that and
this is these are their quotes not mine
you will own nothing and you will be
happy you'll be happy the famous article
I mean now they're doing I talked about
it last week on the show they're running
all these articles in Wall Street
Journal where they go it's now the trend
and not have a dining room you don't
need a living room all of these you know
the Publications are coming out and
they're going like Americans are are
they're they're happy with shrinking
houses and less space and and and and
then they talk about like home builders
are trying to figure out ways to like in
a challenging real estate market still
be profitable what they don't mention is
these home builders are not like Mom and
Pop contractors these are you know D.H
Horton these are massive which are all
on by BlackRock State Street right so so
how is this takeover of the of the
American real estate market uh how can
this how is this preventable well you
know what what I would do immediately
there's a lot of things you can do one
is you can change the tax code to make
it
uh unprofitable because our kids are now
competing against black rocks and
BlackRock has a bottomless Bank book
it has the lowest interest rates on the
planet of anybody
and our kids now have to compete against
that company now why is their rates so
are they lending themselves money how
does it work well first of all they own
all the banks they own all the credit
card companies and they that helps just
because they have a huge Bank book The
you know the uh they're a safe loan so
there's zero risk in wanting to
Blackrock
and so the banks will give them the
lowest possible rates and our kids then
have to compete you know our kids with
no credit rating who have you know a 600
credit rate or whatever it is are paying
not seven percent but maybe 10 interest
right and they're competing against
somebody that's that's getting three
percent interest
it's all right and you know we have
American dream in this country the
promise as World War II your parents
generation my parents generation if you
worked hard if he played by the rules
you could have one job not three and you
can own a house you could take a summer
vacation you could raise a family and
you could and you could put away money
for retirement
that is just not even for anybody that
is actually over now that's hopeful
these kids are not gonna own homes and
and if you don't own a home
you don't care about your community you
don't care about the schools you don't
care you know you that you're less
vested you're less vested and so you're
let you're not you know you're not doing
the things that homeowners do to take
care of them to invest in their
Community to to make it a better place
to live so
and you also have no access to Capital
because
you know if you are a homeowner and you
want to start a small business and you
want to take a risk you get a second
mortgage on your home and you have some
access to Capital because you have an
asset
you can go to the bank with and say look
I I know this may be stupid but I'm
going to start a in our restaurant and
I'm going to put up my home as
collateral and I'm going to do it so but
if you don't have a home
you have no access to Capital that's a
great Point somebody else no way right
to tap the equity in your home you know
you're you're you're you're you're
you're cut off from that source of money
you're also I think people that are are
are not homeowners are subject to
the rising rents yeah all the time
you have no control and the ownership by
these companies
is driving up the cost of rents 40 48 of
people in this country who are renting
are are have anxiety and Cheryl and I
talk about this all the time
you're living paycheck to paycheck in
this country
you know and and and
57 of Americans cannot put their hands
on a thousand dollars if they have
emergency right if you're living
paycheck you are not that fewer than
half of those people are making enough
money to pay for basic human needs for
food transportation and uh and housing
if he and Cheryl you know made this
point to me about when she you know
because she spent most of her life
living paycheck to paycheck right he
said the engine light would come on in
her car and it's like the apocalypse
yeah you know you don't have the money
to pay the mechanic you can't put your
hands on that money and you know that
car is gonna die but you have to get to
work yeah you can't get to work what
happens if you don't have a card you
can't get to work yeah and everything
then starts spiraling to you end up on
the street well it's like you know I
remember being broke being a a comedian
and just trying to make it and like it's
tough to you know opening bank accounts
it's hard yeah you know I was climbing
out of poverty and the type of poverty
that you know we're not talking about
people that are momentarily broke or
talk about in many cases generational
poverty people aren't inheriting homes
they're not you know they're still
locked out of the system in many ways
they are their credit rating is is tough
maybe they maybe they got busted for
smoking weed or there's some you know
criminal record that's preventing them
from getting the job they want the
Democratic party had always styled
itself as kind of the defender of
working people and the defender of
economic Justice what happened
I mean now
I saw this data the other day and I
haven't traced it down to you know
verify it but I what I read the other
day was that 70 of the wealth in this
country is now controlled by Democrat
um versus 30 play Independence and
Republicans and
um so and at the time 10 of the nine of
the ten top
richest counties are now Democrat
counties so it used to be this is
flip-flop from where it was when I was a
kid
where the Republicans were were the rich
with the oligarchs
and the um and the Democrats are you
know working
working for working people right
and so it has flipped and you know and
uh uh you're asking me well I I don't
know it exactly no I saw I watched it
happen
let me just finish yeah this is
interesting Democratic counties
represent 70 percent of U.S GDP 2020
election shows so that's the 2020
elections chaotic and marked by race is
too close to call have nonetheless
reaffirmed that at least in Washington
the two parties now speak for markedly
different segments of the U.S economy
yeah I mean that's that's very
interesting yeah because when you and I
were growing up the Democrats
represented the poor in them that's
right yeah
and the Republicans representative Wall
Street in the oligarchy
but one of the things that I'm going to
do I'm I'm going to immediately create a
new class of mortgages that
you know if you have a rich uncle
you can get a much lower mortgage rate
if if he will close on your loan
go sign your mortgage you can get it
because the bank is looking at his bank
book
other than yours and they're going to
give them a better rate because they're
lower risk
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
give everybody a rich Uncle which is
going to be Uncle Sam and I'm going to
Uncle Sam to co-sign this new class of
mortgages that people get for three
percent
only first-time individual homeowners
can get it
they have to live in that community and
they have to work in that community and
I'm going to give the first 500 000 aids
to teachers because we need to start
supporting our teachers and allow them
to live near the schools and work in
those those places in the way
and I'm going to finance those mortgages
not by increasing our debt which we
should not be doing
uh the I by selling
um three percent bonds that are tax-free
so the market will snap up those bonds
and uh and we'll be able to finance
mortgages so your kids
now will be paying a thousand dollars it
will take a thousand dollars a month off
the typical mortgage of the average
mortgage and you can now get a thousand
a a home for a thousand dollars a month
and uh you know people are paying rent
that for rent and you're building a
middle class and you know when we built
the middle class in this country
after World War II we built a middle
class that became the greatest economic
generator in the history of mankind and
uh we owned when I was a boy half the
wealth on the face of the Earth because
of the American middle class
and now we're tearing it apart and uh
but it began by by making sure everybody
could get into a house after World War
II the GI bill or with these other
programs that allowed every American to
buy a house and once you buy a house you
have access to Capital you can start a
business if you're entrepreneurial and
it released the you know these what
which Franklin Roosevelt called
America's industrial genius you know the
the
inclination for Innovation for
entrepreneurship for
um you know for business development
you can't do that if the if the middle
class does not have access to Capital
which means if they have no equity if
they're living in a rental um you cannot
rebuild them you need to get them into
their own homes how do you stop the
BlackRock Vanguard State Street from
cannibalizing the real estate that we
have in America right now well they're
doing too with a farm real estate and in
fact
that's one of the reasons for the
Ukraine war is that they you know we're
loaning 140 billion dollars a year for
to Ukraine and they're paying it back by
you know we force them to do this
through austerity programs
and it's part of our contract where they
have to put all the Farmland in Ukraine
up for sale it's called the land market
and
um and BlackRock is over there buying
you know the corporations have snapped
up 28 percent of this is the richest
Farmland in the world I'm so stunned and
shocked by by that it is so shy can you
imagine that what I mean how do you but
yeah
how do you stop that you do it you do it
through the tax card I mean we I believe
in free market capitalism sure I don't
believe well we don't have we don't have
that now what we have is Corporate crony
capitalism and Monopoly capitalism
and you need to start uh enforcing the
antitrust laws which is one of the
reasons BlackRock is getting away with
murder there you know they they're they
own all these industries that they've
Consolidated they've vertically
integrated them
and they shouldn't be allowed to do that